in 1994 Morgan Freeman starred in the
Sha Shank Redemption as red the best
friend of the wrongly imprisoned Andy
duin played by Tim Robbins and one of
sha shank penitentiary's most well-known
smugglers in spite of the film bombing
commercially it's gone on to become a
regular feature on any list of the most
inspirational films or movies that will
make you cry amazingly Freeman almost
turned the role down in 2014 Freeman
told Yahoo entertainment that he was
sent the book after being offered the
role explaining and I read the first
page and red was this Irishman so I
closed the book I never read another
line I was like I can't play an Irishman
Freeman ultimately didn't let that stop
him and we got to see him in one of his
best roles a bit of a wink was put in
the script acknowledging the ethnicity
change when defrain asks Freeman's
character why everyone calls him red he
answers maybe it's because I'm Irish